in that one and the game salif started  magnus car saying  it's going to be a franchise  okay excellent i'm i'm very much i'm  very much looking forward to that yeah  let's let's see some rubenstein because  uh yesterday when i when i brought up  that story of george meyer just  publishing his files to prevent people  from playing  a specific line of the rubinstein  against him  uh so that people don't bore him chad  was saying the other way not to get  bored is not to play the rubenstein at  all  which is sort of fair  but on the other hand  it is surprisingly sharp if white wants  it  there is  on the board yeah there's definitely  some lines in rubinstein where play  could become very very concrete and very  very sharp so  uh  it is absolutely not a given that this  will be uh some kind of a some kind of a  boring game  not at all  wow to be honest i'm a little bit  surprised by magnus going e4 against